et on s'y arrête avec Gauthier revinsky
bonjour Gauthier les Russes se
justifient donc parle de représailles
après une incursion sur leur territoire
ça semble être un prétexte
oui donner une certaine manière oui
c'est-à-dire que quand on voit ce qui
est finalement l'effet qui servent de de
base pour les Russes à une représaille
c'est en fait l'incursion de membres du
d'un corps qui s'appelle le corps des
volontaires russes qui sont des Russes
d'extrême droite tout à fait qui
combattent aux côtés de Kiev
c'est l'un des rares des tours rares
mouvements d'extrême droite russe à ne
pas être derrière Poutine parce que pour
le reste ils sont derrière Poutine et là
il y a donc ce groupement c'est
difficile à dire c'est même c'est pas du
niveau de Wagner si vous voulez c'est un
groupement très fortement idéologisé et
qui n'a pas forcément de compte à rendre
à qui que ce soit bon
le fait qu'ils agit derrière la
frontière c'est tout simple pour eux
c'est pour simplement pour une raison
c'est qu'ils sont eux-mêmes russes que
donc en quelque sorte il n'avaient pas à
franchir de frontières mais ce qui est
difficile pour la direction russe c'est
d'avouer que cette chose là a été
commise par un certain nombre finalement
de mercenaires ou mercenaires payés ou
au contraire des volontaires idéologies
mais qui ne sont pas forcément de grands
guerriers on va dire et donc Moscou
hésite à trop parler de cet aspect là
des choses alors qu'il pourrait vous en
souvenez la propagande l'idée qu'il y
ait derrière l'Ukraine des extrêmes
droites des gens extraordinaires ça ça
galvanise Poutine bon là il n'ose pas
trop parler mais en même temps cette
affaire est un prétexte tout trouvé pour
dire vous voyez quand on disait que
l'Ukraine cherchait à nous attaquer et
bien ça n'était pas faux nous en avons
la preuve donc vous pour répondre à
votre question c'est de toute manière
oui c'est un prétexte parce que les
dégâts qui ont été commis par cette
incursion sont certes
de guerre mais enfin ça n'a rien à voir
comme une mesure de commune mesure avec
ce que Moscou est en train de perpétrer
depuis un an donc il y a cette
difficulté mais en même temps la volonté
de coller finalement au récit tout
fabriqué qui est celui de Vladimir
Poutine et des idéologues du régime et
les Russes Gautier ont annoncé avoir
utilisé des missiles hypersoniques
est-ce que c'est une menace qu'on doit
prendre au sérieux oui c'est une menace
qu'il faut prendre au sérieux parce que
dans ce domaine là et la chose est
connue les Russes n'ont cessé
d'améliorer leur armement depuis on va
dire les années Poutine un peu plus tard
disons 2010 2010 il y a eu vraiment un
décrochage occidental parce que
l'Occident pensait que tout ça n'était
fait en Russie que pour redorer le
sentiment de fierté nationale mais que
ça n'aurait pas de de conséquences ou
d'impact sur la géopolitique sur les
affaires du monde et donc il y avait un
décrochage technologique oui et
l'avantage russe c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que Poutine régulièrement
ressort assiste à des à des tests ou ils
ont été lancés c'est ce sont des
missiles qui volent en l'occurrence si
on parle du Kinja le vol à machin
c'est-à-dire 5000 km à l'heure qui
volent très bas ils sont quasiment
indétectables et si ils sont détectables
parce que ça n'est pas forcément là
aussi tout dépend de l'équipement le
problème est ensuite le temps de
réaction de ceux qui sont visés il faut
pouvoir prendre une décision et agir et
c'est encore compliqué donc là il y a
oui il y a une menace qui est certaine
qui est aussi destinée on le voit bien à
masquer les les faiblesses le mot est
faible les faiblesses de l'armée russe
les faiblesses y compris à baroute parce
que on voit bien que si à barco qui a
une décision qui va du côté de Poutine
c'est grâce à Wagner et pas à l'armée
russe donc tout ça c'est fait pour le
masquer et puis surtout on sait très
bien que dans la rhétorique de Poutine
menacé d'armes qui peuvent être
éventuellement chargés d'ogive nucléaire
ça fait toujours son effet et l'idée
c'est évidemment de faire en sorte que
c'est Occident qui décidément a le
mauvais goût de continuer à vouloir
soutenir l'Ukraine et bien qu'ils
prennent peur et là c'est voilà le le la
balle est dans le camp occidental si
vous avez peur il y a plusieurs
possibilités c'est soit répondre en
disant nous ne cédons pas à la peur quel
que soit la menace ou bien se coucher et
dire écoutez Poutine gagnera toujours la
Russie gagnera toujours et là vous savez
je voudrais juste terminer par ça vous
savez qu'il y a par exemple en France un
certain nombre d'intellectuels d'avocats
de chercheurs qui disent
l'Ukraine ne peut pas gagner contre la
Russie ah bon bah oui c'est une évidence
donc c'est un rapport de force immuable
et ça ça quand vous vous affirmez ce
rapport de force comme immuable vous
travaillez main dans la main avec
Poutine c'est aussi clair que ça ça
n'est pas une fanfaronnade ça veut dire
simplement que reprendre certains
arguments sans les contextualiser ou
sans les critiquer c'est une façon de
servir la politique de Poutine comme le
disait la femme de Zayn ce qui un jour
elle disait vous savez si vous
considérez qu'il y a des raisons
géopolitiques à ce conflit c'est que
vous êtes déjà dans la Manche de
Vladimir Poutine effectivement merci
beaucoup Gauthier